things you know his his father passes
away he has this
this thought of you're you're the one
this is it you've got to do this you
guys are together you move out to la am
i right about this you stayed at zac
braff's guest house while you were
shopping for a house yeah well we stayed
at zach brabs guest house because we
were still paying rent in our new york
city apartment
um we were subletting it but not for the
whole amount
and um and zach is so generous he loves
us so much that he was like
stay at my house for free and just kind
of like get your feet wet we had no we
had a goal of buying a home one day but
it definitely wasn't like
we have everything set in place to buy a
home we were just more so it was just
like we're gonna stay at zax we can live
there for free we can save our money and
see if we like living in l.a and then we
happened to
find a home that we could barely afford
and we bought it and how soon after was
was little elvis conceived well elvis
was conceived um right before we moved
to la he was conceived he was well he
was born in june we moved to l.a in
september right so now you got this
little munchkin
around
you're trying to find a place you
finally got a place
and then things are things seems
things seem pretty damn good at this
point yeah well even well to to
to just give a funny antidote when we
first moved into zach's guest house this
two-bedroom two-bath cottage that he
owns
he was living there because his main
house was being completely renovated you
know i live like right around the corner
yeah anyway but go ahead go ahead yeah
so um
as his home was supposed to be finished
but as you know everybody that's gone
through construction knows
if they say it'll be done in may it'll
be done in september
so
he
his house is running late so we have our
plane tickets we're coming nick is
opening rock of ages and zach's like
we're all gonna live together for like
two weeks so it was me
nick ma or elvis our two dogs
zap and his dog all living in the
two-bedroom two-bath guest cottage
then
zack's girlfriend florence arrives and
so then it's zach and florence their dog
nick elvis and i and our two dogs all
living happily together
i mean what the i mean who who went
crazy first had to be zach ironically no
zack
loved it
zach is used to living by himself and so
he all of a sudden had this big family
where every night we were cooking dinner
and eating together drinking wine and
having a bowl he was like not even
wanting to go
thank god for florence because florence
came in and was like we're moving into
your house these people need their space
we need our space we're doing this and
so um
she she was a saving grace i mean we all
actually did get along living together
so well and it was really really fun it
just was hard with the baby because nick
and i and elvis were all in
one room together i mean it was it was
tough and it was tough on me i went
through a little postpartum but we
actually all did i mean you know again
you look back retrospectively and you're
like oh my god like that time was so
magical that we were all living together
at zack's house